all right J is gonna be with us he's in
Florida hi J how are you pretty sad yeah
I have a son that's going into college
next year
my wife and I don't have any money we in
debt we made a lot of foolish mistakes
and I don't know if I should send them
because we don't have the money and I
don't want him to take out any student
loans so I'm kind of I don't know what
to do at this point okay so what's your
household income how do we make about 90
together that's nice okay where do you
live in Florida Orlando okay all right
so have you price Tracy yeah like that
have you got a price on UCF yeah it
around I think around we're gonna send
his guidance counselor recommended him
going to a two-year first the community
college so so where it's about three of
three thousand eighty four thousand per
year so no it's not that much four
thousand a year might be Community
College UCF isn't well how much is that
and we go it's probably gonna be eight
or ten grand a year
well no Community College I'm talking
about okay all right that's fine
Community College for three grand a year
so three grand a year is $250 a month
right you can do that in $9,000 a year
250 bucks a month
by the way junior can deliver pizzas to
this junior guard more no not yet but
he's working at Target after school at
Target okay work for target making money
they're paying him seven bucks they're
killing it no needs to go make some
money you can make fifteen hundred bucks
a month delivering pizza at night while
he goes to school during the day right
Lizzy and uh he's 17 so graduates in May
again next to me yeah so we need three
thousand dollars between now and
September for his first year put his
butt in a car let him deliver pizzas
okay let me cut some grass huh
bye leaf blower rich people are afraid
of leaves and what if he doesn't want to
do it then what then he can sit his butt
at home because if he won't work ain't
gonna go to school did you go to school
I went yeah I got a two-year ain't
finished but yeah if you work while
you're in school I know I didn't
actually yeah I had a part-time job I
got a degree in I got a four-year degree
I work 40 to 60 hours a week for four
years my dad said if you want something
you better leave the cave kill something
and drag it home because I'm not paying
for it and so I want to call me up there
were two million dollars and you're
sitting on a big pile of money and you
just don't pay your kids college I'll
smack you around okay but you don't need
to be smacked around you're just a guy
making 90 grand that's got no money but
they listen the kid can go to school you
did the right thing you're choosing the
way the first two years in community
transfer it over to UCF after that
that's right there in your community
great college its largest College of
America today as a matter of fact
University of Central Florida it's an
incredible place and and it's in state
tuition it's right there in your
backyard he can live in your basement he
can deliver pizzas and cut grass and he
can work his butt off during the summer
the winter the evenings and he can pay
for every bit of this and you can throw
in $250 a month because you are gonna
get on a budget and you make $90,000 a
year so you guys can get through this
together hold on I'm gonna send you a
copy of Anthony O'Neill's book debt-free
degree it's a best-seller and well
that's gonna help you guys do this